So just for completeness, I want to mention some other
techniques besides the traditional ones that we just saw that
can be used for requirements solicitation. And these other
techniques can be divided in three main groups. There are
collaborative techniques that were created to support incremental development
of complex systems with large diverse user populations. An example
of such techniques which is widely used and you
might know is brainstorming. There are also social approaches and
these are approaches, techniques that exploit the social
sciences to better collect information from the stakeholders and
the environment. And among those I just want to mention
ethnographic techniques which are based on the idea of
collecting information on the participants by observing them
in their original environment. Finally cognitive techniques, leverage cognitive
science approaches to discover expert knowledge for example they
can be used to understand the problem solving methods.
And in case you're interested in finding out more about this and
other techniques, I'm providing some references in the notes for the lesson.